hey guys now you know that i always say
that quality is always more important
than quantity especially when it comes
to style but there are also other things
expensive things that you cannot or
should not buy cheap now i know that of
course times are tough and a lot of
people can't afford more expensive
things but as far as it is possible you
need to try because in the long run it's
actually going to save you money if you
buy these things cheap it's is gonna
cost you a lot more money in the long
run if we get into the video you'll
understand what i mean
i'm gonna share with you 10 things that
men should never buy cheap let's get to
it
[Music]
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you hear my channel my name is
daniel and welcome to dlm men's
lifestyle if you haven't subscribed yet
please consider it and also click that
notification bell here so you won't miss
any of our future videos
now let's start with the first thing men
should never bite you
[Music]
a high quality mattress and puller look
you gotta have an awesome bed you gotta
invest in this think about it if you
sleep eight hours a day that is
2920 hours a year that is the amount of
time you spend on your bed and if you
spend this time on a good quality
mattress and a pillow then you'll get
good quality sleep every day of your
life and you will have enough energy
every day to take on the challenges that
this life throws at you if you don't get
good sleep it can lead to fatigue
irritability
mood swings difficulty focusing and
remembering a reduced sex drive
less physical strength a lower ability
to fight off infections you get
increased risk for stroke and asthma
attack and an increased risk for
depression and mental illness
if you can invest in a high quality bed
so that you can get quality rest for
years
to come i'll add some good options for
you in the video description down below
that you can check out
a good phone and a high quality phone
case
you know
a lot of people when something is new
better quality when it's faster i'm
talking about technology here people buy
new phones but then
they don't protect those new phones with
a good
cover a good phone cover they just buy
cheap and fake covers
why if it falls and breaks that cheap
cover is not going to protect your
expensive phone just buy a more
expensive good quality phone case that
will not only protect your phone but
also make it look better
an electric toothbrush
i'm so surprised that a lot of guys
don't take care of their teeth it
represents you whenever you smile
whenever you talk your appearance
you only have the teeth that you have
and you got to take care of them i used
to have a
cheap toothbrush when i was younger when
i got old i got another one but then one
day i realized i got to respect myself
enough to take good care of myself when
it comes to grooming and that includes a
better toothbrush
according to dentalhealth.org
scientists found that electric
toothbrushes clean teeth and gums much
better than manual toothbrushes and
people who use an electric toothbrush
have healthier gums less tooth decay and
also keep their teeth for longer
compared with those who use a manual
toothbrush
[Music]
shoes
look you can buy cheap shoes because
they are everywhere but in a few months
they're just gonna break
it will wear out and then you'll have to
buy a new pair and then a new pair a new
and it's just gonna continue and
continue until you're probably dead
so you're wasting a lot more money at
the end you spend a lot more
and you're also taking time which also
is money time is money you take that
time to go one or two hours to go and
look for a new pair of shoes every
single time so in the end you pay more
for cheap shoes that you would have paid
for a good more expensive but a high
quality pair of shoes that will last you
for a long time and
that looks a lot better more stylish let
me give you an example i bought these
good quality boots 11 years ago and they
still look good today i'll also add my
other shoes from oliver cabell and ace
marks in the video description below if
you want to check him out i'll do the
same for all the other items that i'm
talking about in this video
a stylish bag
you can't go wrong with a good quality
bag that will last you for a long time
the reasoning behind this is basically
the same as the shoes buy cheap and it
will break it won't last and you will
have to buy again and again i bought
this letter back when i was 22 years old
and i still use it today and this one is
my favorite you probably already saw it
on the banner of my channel buying the
more expensive the higher quality things
just like this bag
will always be better than the cheap
things that always break and always let
you down
will save money in the long run
a good coffee maker
if you love coffee as much as i do
it is an investment think about it if
you buy two cups of coffee every day it
will cost you around seven dollars a day
let's say that is 2555
a year
that's a lot of money and you also waste
a lot of time think about it when you go
to the coffee shop every day that queue
you have to stand in and wait for your
coffee think about how much time you
waste in a year this coffee machine here
cost me only 700
so even if i buy my own coffee beans and
use my own electricity i will still save
a lot of money and time year after year
after year now yes a coffee machine is
expensive but it is an investment
because it will save you a lot of money
for years to come
and if you do decide to get one get a
good quality one one that makes awesome
coffee because you're gonna have to
drink that coffee every day for years to
come and you want it to be great
buying a good laptop or a pc
this is something you just gotta dig
deep take out the money and buy the best
one that you can according to your
budget especially if you work from home
and need a good laptop for your job now
of course this depends on what you do
with your laptop but the better you buy
the better quality it is the longer it
will last you just think about a little
bit think back i'm 34 years old right
now i'm not going to be able to use
laptops from 10 years ago because it's
just too old you need more space to
store all your videos or your photos a
bigger hard drive you need better ram a
faster computer because it needs to be
able to handle fast work at home if
other people have fast computers and you
don't if they have fast internet you
don't you're gonna get behind and the
same goes for graphics if you need to
edit videos for example like i do being
a youtuber you can't have a slow bad
computer you need good graphics you need
a fast computer fast ram and you need a
lot of space you don't want to get
behind so just don't buy just a cheap
one just just for now just for a few
years buy a good one that will last you
for a long time
[Music]
light bulbs
a lot of people do it and i don't
understand why when when they live
when they go and they move into a new
house they try to do everything as cheap
as they can
i don't understand this because cheap
now does not mean cheap for the long run
he's gonna you're just gonna waste a lot
more money in the long run
that's the same when it comes to things
like light bulbs just use a little bit
more money and get led light bulbs why
because number one they use less
electricity saving you money on your
electricity bill number two they also
last a lot longer they will last between
10 000 and 25 000 hours where a normal
light bulb usually lasts for only 1 000
hours
a good quality watch
or a few watches that will fit in with a
few different outfits
if you buy cheap watches
cheap watches for some reason just
always break they never last
why
because they're cheap they're made of
cheap materials it's always better to
invest in a more expensive good quality
watch
now you don't have to go super expensive
like this watch from blank paint costing
you 117
on amazon that's just crazy i mean
think about everything that you can do
with that money think about all the
people you can feed with that money
[Applause]
that is just crazy
i think people who buy that kind of
watches
being so materialistic
selfish people did you know the most
expensive watch in the world is the
hallucination by graf diamonds which
will cost you 55 million
so no you don't have to go that
expensive but there is something special
about getting a good quality watch for
life and then if you pass on you can
leave it to your son or if you don't
have a son your daughter think how
special it will be to them i'll add some
great options for you in the video
description down below
outgoing quality clothes when you're at
home you can probably wear whatever you
want because you're at home but if you
go out it's awesome to have good quality
clothes that will fit in with every
occasion for example a great suit that
fits you perfectly for that important
business meeting that leather jacket
that's perfect for when you are on the
move or on a date and the jeans that are
made for your leg shape that never looks
old and that fits in with most outfits i
can go on and on and on but i think you
get it
and remember
comfort style and price always need to
go together when it comes to clothes
and you can go cheap but you're not
going to look as good and it's going to
cost you more money at the end because
you'll always have to go and buy new
clothes
cheap clothes
they will always just wear and tear and
you will have to go buy new ones instead
just buy good quality from the start
that will last you a lot longer start
today invest in yourself invest in good
quality clothes that will last you for
years to come
just a bonus tip
good quality cologne
move away from these cheap drugstore
products
and get yourself great quality cologne
like vince camuto terra
sava by christian duel
versace eros or dolcin cabana the one
for men i'll also add a few other
options in the video description down
below but if you buy good quality
cologne you use it you'll automatically
smell good for your wife or your
girlfriend for other people and that
just shows them that you are a real
gentleman if you also have good manners
these days it's like
i don't know how to say this but it's
true
guys are becoming worse and worse and
worse because they have less manners
they don't even know what it means to be
a real man anymore now we are talking
about material things but there are
other things more important things that
makes you a real man that is more
important than just material stuff if
you want to know what that is then check
out this video here and i'll see you
there and always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys